i don't know if you've heard
zuck's had a rough week bro yeah
facebook's had a rough week it's been
rough started with a whistleblower it
started with all these documents and
leaks coming out of what the hell's
really facebook's got going on
instagram's got going on that's how it
started then it went after that was
sunday night then monday everything went
down for six hours
right facebook instagram whatsapp
uh the messenger everything down down
down down you know how much zuck lost
in a span of six hours apparently that's
six billion oh is it behind me it's
right behind you oh my goodness six
billion you think that's i think that's
good that's nothing because people are
saying oh he was well that is something
okay how much
what's his net worth
uh mark zuckerberg is worth uh it
obviously network fluctuates like
literally every day but it's more like
it's it's like
it's north of a hundred billion dollars
i think it's probably closer to 120
billion i think he'll be certainly in
the top five top 10 wealthiest people in
the world i think also bezos is number
one i think elon musk is sometimes
number one number two bernard arnold up
there warren buffett's up there zuck's
up there yeah and then how much money
does he have buried under a freaking
rock somewhere okay so i don't know i
think six billion
you don't feel bad for zuck i don't feel
bad for him
it's just like he farted he lost six
bills oh next oh there it goes it's fine
anyway
he's worth about 120 billion you know
what his annual salary is by the way 35
000 a year what is it one dollar
he makes one dollar a year
it's all stock yeah he's got the company
equity in the company there's a lot of
there's a lot of big people out there
that say look i don't need a salary i'm
good
right mayor bloomberg
you know when when he was mayor of new
york arnold schwarzenegger when he was
governor buck
the google boys that's sergey brin and
um
and larry page dollar right oracle larry
larry ellison dollar
um i think mitt romney at one point was
just taking a dollar salary when he was
the governor point is this they get paid
in stock
in uh shares of the company in equity of
the company they don't need a salary but
you know who does need a salary who's
that the employee's a facebook yeah they
need one so i said you know what
everything happened this week with
facebook people just talk about how much
zuck lost how much facebook has lost in
stock like they've had a rough
week they've had a rough month their
stock has sort of been going down
but
there's other employees out there and i
wanted to find out how much are they
making right how much are these
facebook employees making now obviously
the salary depends on their role their
experience location so for example if
you're a data analyst in california
you're going to make maybe 130 grand
versus if you're a data analyst in texas
you make closer to 100 grand that's just
how it works these days especially when
people work in remote you know location
location location
they're going to pay you based on
those factors those criteria your role
your experience but certainly your
location so
here are a couple of the positions at
facebook and how much they make and
these guys make loot by the way do they
like these guys make loot all right okay
so um
here's a couple examples so there's an
analytics
guy
or gal all right they're they're they're
analytics data analytics that's their
role okay they're
data analytics technician yeah you know
how much they make a year between 170
and 200 grand a year now these are the
people that are focusing on the likes
the comments the shares the algorithms
and that making sure people are watching
the ads now obviously that's how
facebook makes its money ads
yeah but for six hours there were no ads
it was down so that person has some
explaining to do
yikes okay so that is the analytics lead
over at facebook now
when everything was going down people
were obviously freaking out fix it like
i don't think facebook didn't benefit
like there's conspiracy theorization
facebook purposely did it because of the
whistleblower so they purposely wanted
to put facebook down to take the eyes
off the whistleblower i said how does
that do anything beneficial to you
because that's just gonna make more
people question what the hell's going on
at facebook it's everyone's gonna be
talking about it's down and then
obviously the stories and the conspiracy
theories go there so i don't buy that at
all i think facebook did did not want to
stay down yeah you lost six billion
dollars ain't no joke so this next big
group of people will talk about their
salaries these are the people who are
freaking out the most
when facebook went down because it was
their job to keep it up to keep it up to
fix it we're talking about the engineers
yeah right the data engineer the
software engineer the security engineers
these people are making me freaking out
exactly these people are making between
100 and 200 000 a year
okay so they're making a couple hundred
grand a year to make sure
this doesn't happen this doesn't happen
so step into my office why because
you're fired
okay and then there's the engineering
director oh that guy's out the director
of engineering this person makes 360 000
a year okay a lot of money thousand
bucks a day right thousand bucks a day
he's getting paid the big bucks
obviously so like this doesn't
happen
but it happened you idiot all right you
getting goddamnit
um
so
these are the people that are making
money on the engineering side of things
we talked about the best majors to go to
in college a lot of more is engineering
because you can end up working for
facebook or a big tech company make a
couple hundred grand a year no problem
so those the the salaries range from as
much as a hundred thousand to as much as
360 000 for being an engineer or an
engineering
director um and then there and then
there's these people that gotta
once everything is up and running they
gotta clean up the mess they to explain
what the hell just happened to facebook
right we're talking about these the
following people they got to clean up
the mess the exec the executive
communications manager they make between
230 and 270 000 a year
you know what you know how they can
communicate you know you should start
with
i'm sorry
my bad
how about that for a little
communication
that's my beat that's my b that's my b
dude just apologize i leaned on the
button that was my bad you got the ad
agency director making 330 000 a year
okay
the ad agency there's millions and
millions of ads that didn't run aka
loss of revenue that person's got some
explaining to do to their clients and
then you got some strategist content
strategy
content strategist
making a buck 20 a year to as much as
okay
and then you get the creative strategist
making 265
dollars a year
yeah you're gonna get pretty creative to
flip this situation on its head okay
clean this mess up so as we talked about
facebook stock has plummeted um this
past week so this past month it actually
hasn't done so good but it reached the
tipping point on october 4th that was a
monday um
what's the takeaway here david what's
the takeaway here you know people want
to focus on zuk people want to focus on
the six billion that he potentially lost
you had
you had you you had zero tears survivors
okay but these people are making
hundreds and hundreds of thousand
dollars a year yeah and someone's
getting fired over this someone's losing
a job yeah um
i don't know man i mean i've heard some
things some
chinese hackers
like it's it's like
do you have people to blame at some
point like
maybe it's like a scolding or something
but you're right i mean all these i mean
there's someone to blame you young man
give me your old man impressions
let this happen and that's what you did
why i ought to be anyway
when facebook goes down like thinking
about how much money these guys are
making it's not like these guys are
making minimum wage working at
mcdonald's and the ice cream machine
goes down right but then there's always
someone better than you that can go past
your defenses then you got to just find
hey look this is what happened but i'm
you've got to fix it because i've been
doing this i know what they did aha and
that can fix it what are you going to go
pay some other schmuck it's also all
about loyalty and trust i've trusted
this guy and he's been loyal to me and
something happened but i know that he's
going to fix it because that's a great
point for years loyalty and trust is
better oh i don't care what the salary
is i trust this guy well then trust some
other guys okay well anyway that's how
much money
facebook employees are making
minimum six figures some of them are
making two 300 grand a year
to make sure that facebook operates
facebook a lot of hot water
right there's the good the bad the ugly
of what's going on there there's the
good the
can we get a picture of him with all
that money no not all that money all
that sunscreen on his face oh yeah yeah
sunscreen this guy does not want to tan
no matter what
what do we got here
oh
images hit images zuckerberg sunscreen
there it is
i love this
yeah this homie we know exactly who you
are zuck there he is anyway
this was his face uh when it all
happened
that's natural that's not even sunscreen
he's shook
that's what happened to you
god that is something that's an
aggressive amount of suns that is that
is pretty wild
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken